I take no pleasure in what I'm about
city but President Obama how dare you
sir last week in talking about the debt
sequester you uttered this abomination
the fact that they don't take it means
that I should somehow of you know do a
Jedi mind-meld with these folks get it
straight sir
you clumsily combine Star Wars and Star
Trek
it's Jedi mind-trick Vulcan mind-meld
mixed together it did not taste like
chocolate and peanut butter sir
it tasted like a but a super gross but
I've known many nerds sir I've broken
bread with nerds
you are no nerd mr. Obama
I thought America had historically
elected its first nerd president who
also happened to be black you had us
fooled mr. Obama it started with your
claims of liking the wire now I think
you probably confused all the characters
on the wire did you think bubbles was
Omar and Omar was bubbles Avon Barksdale
was stringer Bell and Marlo was a
Barksdale and stringer Bell was Marlo
and Lester Freeman was bunk and bunk was
lester freamon and McNulty was Michael
Chiklis from the shield you guys all
followed that right I thought it was
cool that you hired Kumar of Harold and
Kumar Fame to work with the
administration did you actually mean to
hire Harold mr. president should it have
been John Cho getting laid in Charlotte
North Carolina the Democratic National
Convention mr. president
you Oh John chose sex I'll admit it was
pretty neat that the White House
responded to an actual petition to build
a Death Star why would we spend
countless taxpayer dollars on a death
star with a fundamental flaw that can be
exploited by a one man starship but in
your mind mr. president who's piloting
that's
ship wall-e Wharf Slimer Dracula we need
to know this gas calls your entire
presidency into question are you going
to walk into the Hall of Justice and ask
hey where's Iron Man where are you gonna
put on the walking dead and wonder what
Anna Paquin is up to will you confuse
David Brent with Michael Scott the
British office is better by the way
where does it end please get it together
before one of your mistakes takes us
right into World War three or something
far worse World War Z in closing
President Obama you owe an apology to
all nerds from sea to shining sea
without it you do not have our sword or
our axe
thank you and may the force make you
live long and prosper that was fun
you think Obama's gonna watch it no so
if Congress was to enact a nerd themed
federal holiday what would it be and how
would you celebrate it leave us an
answer in the comment section below
best answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt that's all we got I'm how
running by bike hey guys it's Hal thanks
for watching I'm in a new movie coming
out in AMC theaters this weekend called
serial buddies it's the first serial
killer buddy comedy go to serial buddies
calm for more info and see it like nine
times